morgens um halb fünf beginnt für die
wanderarbeiter in der hauptstadt der
kampf um einen job es ist ein kampf ums
tägliche überleben rompuy hat es eilig
und er will eigentlich keine fragen
beantworten er will einen auftrag es ist
schwer einen job zu finden warum wegen
der pandemie manchmal haben wir nur
wenige tage im monat arbeit
wan kui lebt seit vielen jahren in
peking so schlimm war es noch nie viele
bezirke sind dem lockdown er hat nur
seine körperkraft zu bieten ein paar
hundert euro im monat verdient er zu
wenig zum leben
es reicht einfach nicht auf dem markt
vorne bieten sich die wanderarbeiter an
und finden keine arbeit wegen der
pandemie sind viele fabriken zu sie
brauchen uns nicht
die imbiss leben bieten ein billiges
kräftiges frühstück an drinnen sitzen
die wanderarbeiter und löffeln für 20
cent bohneneintopf auch die geschäfte
der suppenküche laufen schlecht wie geht
es ihnen
nicht gut keine kunden
jeden morgen kommen hunderte von
tagelöhnern auf den marktplatz von
teenagern etwa 30 kilometer außerhalb
von 4 sie nehmen jeden job an straßen
reparieren bäume pflanzen dreck
aufsammeln gebäude reinigen in china
gibt es noch 292 millionen
wanderarbeiter sie verlassen ihre heimat
um in den reicheren großstädten geld zu
verdienen
wenn ich nichts finde dann muss ich mir
etwas überlegen
bis wann gibt es denn noch eine chance
nach 6 uhr wird es schwierig
peugeot hat nichts gefunden und ist
bereit uns zu zeigen wer wohnt er ist 55
jahre alt lebt seit jahren in peking und
kommt aus der nachbarprovinz red er war
einmal bauer und hoffte auf das glück in
der hauptstadt
ich hatte einen kleinen hof
damit konnte ich rund 800 euro verdienen
musste davon aber noch die arbeiter
bezahlen
danach die fast nichts für mich zum
leben deshalb bin ich wanderarbeiter und
bestelle nicht mehr mein feld seine
kammer kostet ihn knapp 45 euro erteilt
sie sich doch die pandemie bedroht ihn
manchmal hat er nicht genug zu essen
vor corona habe ich fast 1600 euro im
monat verdient
da ich jetzt nicht jeden tag einen job
finde komme ich gerade mal auf 290 euro
es ist schwer davon zu leben
das offizielle china wir nicht über die
herrschende ungerechtigkeit im land
sprechen der reichtum in den glitzernden
hochhaustürmen blendet die gesellschaft
ein problem für die kommunistische
partei die gleichheit predigt die null
kowitz strategie der kommunistischen
partei versagt und schadet der
wirtschaft des landes also denn sie hält
an ihr fest das schadet seinem acht
image sie den finger persönliche haftung
für diese 0 kowitz strategie übernommen
wenn diese strategie jetzt scheitert
dann leidet seine reputation als
effizienter allwissender all
kontrollieren da herrsche es ist 6.30
morgens viele werden jetzt unruhig die
busse die mit unternehmer vorfahren die
jobs anbieten werden belagert
es ist ein facharbeiter zu finden
es gibt so viele
wieder keinen job zu finden das heißt
kein geld das sie ihren familien daheim
schicken können und oft heißt es auch zu
holen
ich habe niemals ein richtiges warmes
essen
ich esse jeden tag nur trockenes brot
niemals fleisch oder reis jeden tag nur
pro zu frühstück zum mittags abends
nudeln
solche szenen von armen verzweifelten
menschen wollen pekings machthaber der
welt nicht zeigen denn offiziell hat
kein land die pandemie besser im griff
als china
den mann mit der schwarzen jacke hat die
stadt peking geschickt er soll die
wanderarbeiter vertreiben
haut endlich ab die dürfen sich hier
nicht versammelt hören sie auf mich zu
filmen
können sie damit auf
wir sind sie
das geht sie nichts an sie verletzten
meine rechte und dann geht er wieder los
die wanderarbeiter zu verscheuchen oder
wo alle leute die einen job suchen hauen
ab
eine arbeiterinnen truppe ist zum
pflanzen angeheuert der frauen mütter
großmütter die meisten weit über 50
werden jetzt für die nächsten acht
stunden gekürzten euro erde umgraben ein
neuer industriepark soll entstehen der
chinas schwächelndes wirtschaftswunder
befeuern soll der aufseher passt auf
dass die arbeiterinnen sich nicht
beschweren die antworten vorsichtig
ich vermisse mein zuhause aber ich habe
keine wahl
die wanderarbeiter machen die täglichen
jobs die die wohlhabende mittelschicht
nicht will sie sind so etwas wie der
maschinenraum der das leben in den
hochhäusern angenehm macht
am boden ist der traum vom aufstieg hart
erarbeitet werden millionen von
wanderarbeitern den job kämpfen ums
überleben
die pandemie macht das noch schwieriger
ich wünsche mir mehr geld zu verlieren
ich will nach hause zu meiner frau und
meinem enkelkind die familie ist das
wichtigste aber um sie zu unterstützen
muss sich immerfort
harry wird morgen wieder zum markt
bilden und sich anbieten ab 4 30 mit all
den anderen sie hoffen dass bald ein
pandemie zu ende geht und dass es dann
vielleicht wieder jobs gibt